c'est plus long oui comme ça mais vous
avez vous rapprocher plus du véritable
goût de la plante marque chenu est un
amoureux du goût depuis 20 ans il
travaille le produit brut pour en
extraire la véritable saveur et créent
des sirops aujourd'hui siro verveine
gingembre les bouteilles
réapprovisionneront la ferme de gally
chaque détail compte surtout la
température dont 420 effectueront le
sucre a déjà un taux plus bas à monter
et va s'épaissir
moi si je faisais ça avec le gingembre
vu que celui la jambre frais je vais
changer le goût du japon via un peu
caramélisé
heureusement le goût va changer ça plus
être pareil
moi je veux garder le côté frais du jour
la préparation n'ira donc pas au delà de
70 degrés un véritable travail
d'alchimiste qui lui a valu le nom de sa
boutique ce sirop c'est le début de son
activité le premier d'une longue série
installé à chevreuse depuis trois ans
marque propose aujourd'hui plus de 70
créations différentes aussi bien déçu
passons fait mes fromages avec des
fromages avec des légumes avec des
viandes donc savoir que le seront peut
être utilisé comme un condiment comme
une sauce c'est ça l'idée
il ya deux ans on a créé avec champion
de france de barista un sirop qu'on
appelait velours de tahiti et qui est à
0 réalisé que la fleur de tiaré fraîche
et puis récemment il ya eu un sirop de
sureau roma fruités épicés ou
prestigieux une gamme qui se décline
selon les envies marque organise des
ateliers pour faire découvrir son savoir
faire aux curieux et satisfaire les
palais des gourmands